d'un bon café [ __ ] s'éloigne
merci merci mon petit peu mais froid il
est froid les frères le chef très bon
stagiaire chez le petit débrief de
l'émission de la semaine dernière
beaucoup de gens se sont plaints qu'on
reçoit michel cymes on voit déjà
beaucoup à la télévision vraiment désolé
cette semaine rien à voir en soit michel
drucker
sur twitter aussi beaucoup de gens ont
pris au premier degré les vannes de
michel cymes sur nagui alors je vous
rassure ils sont copains si metz il a
dit que nagui il est chiant il a le
melon c'est pas vrai bien entendu il a
dit aussi nagui il ya que lui qui
comprend ses blagues bon ça par contre
c'était vrai
[Applaudissements]
alors ce soir on a un magnifique plateau
c'est incroyable ce soir c'est bien il
ya du poids retraite ça c'est sûr c'est
impressionnant c'est vrai non ce qui est
très bien c'est que tout le monde est
resté jeune ça c'est incroyable michel
drucker il est resté jeune grâce au vélo
jean michel jarre il est resté jeune
grâce au voyage enrico macias grâce à la
musique et thierry ardisson grâce à sa
maquilleuse
ce qui est fou c'est qu'on vous a tous
connu il ya 30 ans avec la même tête moi
je me mets à la place d'un mec qui sort
aujourd'hui d'un coma de 20 ans
originaire isap ya le conflit
israélo-palestinien sert tf1 sur france
3 il est question pour un champion la et
regarde ardisson et enrico macias jean
michel jarre et michel drucker pour lui
il a juste fait une sieste de deux
heures
[Applaudissements]
michel drucker michel je vous adore je
vous ai vu samedi dernier chez laurent
ruquier vous avez prêté un journaliste
de gros con moi michel il se lâche enfin
le problème c'est comme ça fait 73 ans
qui se retient le groupe contre la
semaine dernière c'était juste
l'apéritif regardé l'émission jusqu'au
bout parce qu'à mon avis dans dix
minutes et un fils de [ __ ] qui va partir
[Applaudissements]
jean michel jarre jean michel jarre
c'est la classe dans les années 70-80
vous étiez considéré comme l'incarnation
du futur au même titre que les bogdanoff
voilà alors c'est sûr que quand on les
voit on dit que le futur a priori
c'était pas la chirurgie esthétique ça
c'est sympa
mais bravo jean michel grasa aux
millions de gens qui sont venus voir vos
concerts vous êtes rentré quatre fois
dans le guiness book alors il est pas 42
entre le mec qui jettent désolé avec son
nez celui qui soulève des parpaings que
ses testicules
alors ici mesdames et messieurs ma
mission est de poser les questions trop
con que thierry ardisson ici présent n'a
pas voulu vous posez première question
jean michel jarre david guetta vous
considère comme son père spirituel
vous n'avez jamais pensé à l'avortement
spirituel
inna modja vous êtes chanteuse mannequin
actrice bref vous savez que si votre
album marche pas vous pouvez toujours
être femme de nicolas sarkozy
le gros avantage
enrico macias alors lorsque vous
chantiez en 2007 à qu'elles sont jolies
les filles de sarkozy vous pensiez pas
nadine morano j'espère
[Applaudissements]
et pour terminer michel drucker vous
avez été élue personnalité la plus
emblématique du paf depuis 1950 devant
léon zitrone jacques martin et guy lux
c'était quoi le critère pour gagner
c'était le talent ou être en vie
bon allez je vais très bonne émission
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux